christophe crépin porte parole du
syndicat france police bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur été
france quand vous entendez cet exil et
jaune s'exprimer est ce que vous vous
dites voilà il ya quand même du vrai il
ya un malentendu avec la police avec une
partie des citoyens des sciences est
entendue avec la police bien sûr que ma
part et et syndicales dès le départ on a
dit qu'il ya une fracture sociale qui
avait des gens qui avaient des doléances
qu'ils étaient légitimes
on était ouvert à tous sauf évidemment
aux violences qui ont été commises par
certaines personnes qui voulaient se
dire des gilet jaune mais qui était en
fait des black blocs qui venait prendre
des collègues en exutoire mais en effet
notre pays connaît une fracture sociale
assez conséquente
c'est sans précédent si j'ose dire il ya
eu un avant et un après mouvement des
gilet jaune c'est ça qui a créé comme on
dit le grand malentendu et qui est en
forme ou résumées en fait il ya eu un
avant et après il ya eu il ya eu dans
notre pays une attente profonde au
suffrage universel c'est la raison pour
laquelle ils ont élu monsieur macron
parce qu'ils pensaient qu'il y aurait un
changement radical ce changement n'a pas
fait jour il ya des gens qui doivent
choisir entre faire le plein de leur
véhicule et leurs plats réfrigérateurs
et des gens qui ont vraiment une
fracture sociale nous mêmes les
policiers nous avons une somme citoyens
policiers et nous avons des fois le
choix à faire entre faire le plein de
véhicules pour aller au travail et
européennes le frigidaire aujourd'hui
vous vous trouvez dans une position
délicate
finalement parfois un policier sur ce
plateau m'avait dit le coeur à geaune le
coeur jaune voilà et finalement d'être
obligé d'être sur le terrain pour
remplir sa mission imagine que ça doit
être peut-être compliqué l'état d'esprit
des troupes actuellement c'est très
difficile surtout qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui même au jeu c'est
l'interview nous avons des propos de
notre ministre et d'autres président de
la république qui ne satisfont pas du
tout ma parité syndicale justement donc
j'allais bien évidemment y venir
emmanuel macron qui s'est exprimé
aujourd'hui notamment aussi sur les
retraites mais il a parlé de ces
violences policières avec cette affaire
show via dont on m'a parlé également le
président qui demandent des propositions
pour améliorer la déontologie votre
réaction
mais on n'a pas entendu monsieur macron
pauvres d anthologie la déontologie nous
avons à cause de telle déroute au logis
qui ce qui se vit dans notre profession
nous sommes la profession la plus
contrôlée que ce soit il la police ou la
gendarmerie on est contrôlé à tous les
niveaux nous avons l'inspection générale
de la police
nous avons le parquet nous avons le
défenseur des droits systématiquement
dès qu'on a une vidéo
la hiérarchie nous convoque et nous
demandent des explications
on n'a pas attendu d'avoir ce genre de
déclaration qui pour moi une déclaration
politique et qu'il ne va pas
certainement pas aller dans le sens de
mes collègues c'était la même chose
ailleurs pour christophe castaner ne
peut le compteur le monsieur macro
monsieur 15 terrains mais c'est quand
même lui qui donne le la de
voilà c'est quand même votre patron à la
police donc on imagine que je le sais
mais j'aimerais bien que nous ils s'en
souviennent que l'on a besoin d'avoir un
patron qui sont épris de ses troupes en
fait voilà justement vous estimez que
christophe castaner y est peut-être pour
quelque chose
voilà dans ces tensions dont j'ai le
plus profond respect à l'institution mon
pays du président de la république de
monsieur castaner nommant il faut pas
qu'ils oublient que la police nationale
et la gendarmerie nous traversions une
période qui est sans précédent et qui
est une période très difficile nous
avons attiré son attention par des
intersyndicales qui n'ont pas été
suivies d'effet
même sur les retraites nous sommes pas
aligner poli gendarmerie nous allons
nous sommes dans un désarroi total
le dernier collet qui a mis fin à ses
jours la mi parce qu'il ne se
reconnaissait plus dans les forces ou
qui ne sont plus auprès des citoyens et
pourtant l'été un poste de commandement
je pense que ça doit attirer l'attention
de nos gouvernants moi j'attends de mes
gouvernants qui soit à la hauteur de la
gouvernance que nous travaillons pour
eux ont parlé des suicides de policiers
il ya également eu un policier n'en
démord radio ouï oui psg d'échangés deux
collègues qui ont mis fin à leur jour
une femme un homme et j'ai aussi à mes
collègues qui ont votants temps
d'arrêter un voleur qui est quand même
le coeur de notre métier s'est fait
rouler dessus et malheureusement elle
est décédée et je profite de votre
chaîne pour adresser toutes mes
condoléances à sa famille
effectivement plusieurs centaines de
policiers ont observé une minute de
silence aujourd'hui en hommage à ce
collègue clairement vous vous sentez
soutenu aujourd'hui par la hiérarchie
dans ces épreuves
alors moi j'aimerais que notre ministère
d'emploi en l'occurrence comme les de
liam ce questionnaire soit le plus
proche des policiers qu'il n'ait pas
changé ton et qu'ils nous soutiennent
parce que nous sommes souvent très
souvent agresser on nous envoie en
première ligne pour régler des conflits
sociaux qui ne sont pas toujours de
notre fait bien évidemment aujourd'hui
nous ne pouvons pas et toujours que la
réponse aux retraites au gilet jaune et
demain matin ça va être quoi
vous avez justement l'impression que ces
manifestants vous amalgame vous au
gouvernement parfois abc le but en fait
franchement on nous mais on est vite
voir là oui c'est le but je pense que
gouvernement nous met en exergue trois
en fait la seule réponse et nous mettre
des décollectes comme modèle qu'on le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on met des
jeunes policiers qui sont pleins de
vigueur qui ça fait un travail mais on
les forme pas on n'a plus aucune
formation continue
l'école des gardiens de la paix c'était
12 mois après c'est passé à onze mois
maintenant c'est un neuf mois il faut
une formation on peut pas donner des
armements à des policiers si on ne les
forme pas et si on ne les entraîne pas
vous allez me parler de la mort de ceux
de ce monsieur qui est décédé son
scooter on a vu à la famille a reçu
aujourd'hui par christophe castaner qui
est très déçue la famille un évidemment
parce que ses agents n'ont pas été
suspendues alors monsieur monsieur
l'allemand qui n'est pas un homme connu
pour sa tendresse est rendu au
commissariat de police du 7ème
arrondissement
thibault de montbrial qui est en charge
cette avocate qui est en charge la
défense de mes collègues je les ai eu
tout à l'heure avant de venir me disais
paix collègues et effondré mes collègues
ils sont dans une situation qui est
terrible parce que les gestes
d'intervention qu'elles ont utilisé pour
essayer de faire en sorte que cet
individu soit ils maîtrisent heures de
bonnes conditions aussi bien pour lui
que pour nous n'ont pas fonctionné pour
nous c'est un échec
nous sommes tous des pères et des mères
de famille quand on a une intervention
qui se déroule dans ce style là on reste
pas insensible et on est effondré mais
christophe crépin ce genre de geste
justement est-ce qu'il faut encore les
avoir voilà ce que ça doit être encore
accepté entre guillemets par par an
voilà le code 2
j'espère comment on appelle ça des
procédures pour ça je vais pas aller au
devant de l'enquète de l'inspection
générale qui ne fait jamais de cadeau ça
faut que les gens qui vous regardent le
sache que l'inspection générale ne fait
pas de cadeau à la police nationale
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
l'inspection générale et là ils ont un
cadre d' enquête ils font leurs cadres
dans quai ils vont déterminer d'un point
de vue administratif et de la point de
vue judiciaire quelles sont les
responsabilités de mes collègues mais
aujourd'hui mes collections dans un état
ici lisons ils ont provoqué parce qu'il
ya également une concomitance entre
leurs interventions et le décès de joie
après de ce pauvre livreurs et nous
mêmes nous présentons nos condoléances à
cette famille parce que c'est un échec
merci en tout cas christophe enfin
devenu parlé avec sincérité en tout cas
sur le plateau d'ayrté france